(electronic music)
- So we live in Brooklyn, our
show takes place in Brooklyn,
- So we figured what
better way than to invite
the newest members of the Brooklyn Nets
to a two on two game.
- Andray Blatche, Reggie Evans.
Thanks for coming on our
show, we appreciate it.
We're gonna play this
game that we came up with
called the backpack of disabilities.
- So here are the rules of the game:
it's just like two-on-two,
but you just gotta pull a disability
out of this backpack. This
new Brooklyn Nets backpack
that we made.
- Oh, this is a good one. Prescription.
He's gotta wear some prescription glasses.
(funk music)
- Substitute white guy. You gotta sit out.
- This is gonna be great to
play basketball with you.
(Andray laughs)
(electronic music)
- Side chicks here,
they're just gonna come
yell at y'all while we play basketball.
- What are you doing? You suck.
- Get off the court!
- Go home.
- No, you go home!
(yelling)
- [Keith] Side chicks.
We got tiny lawyer. So
you've got a tiny lawyer.
- How you doing? Jack Rabinowitz.
- Hi, Reggie Evans man,
nice to meet you too.
I don't need no lawyer.
- That's tight turtleneck.
You just gotta wear a tight turtleneck.
- I keep getting the worst ones, man.
(drum music)
- You can't dunk with a tight turtleneck.
- [Reggie] Pregnant?
- [Lucas Brother] Oh no, you
got the four months pregnant.
- Oh, oh, my water just broke.
- Y'all have asthma.
(mumbles)
- [Andray] I've gotta put an old sandwich
in my shooting hand.
- [Reggie] Tickle monster.
- He's a monster he just
likes tickling people.
(laughs)
- I wanna thank y'all for coming out,
Reggie Evans, Andray Blatche,
thanks for coming and playing.
I'm sorry we had to win like that,
it's embarrassing for
y'all, but it's our game.
It's backpack of disabilities.
(funk music)